just 800 miles from the North Pole and
climate change is ripping apart the ice
the Arctic is warming twice as fast as
the rest of the planet and on the
Norwegian archipelago of Svalbard the
glaciers are shrinking the increase in
ice loss that is an increase in sea
level the sea level rise will continue
and it will accelerate in the future
that is the problem with Arctic ice loss
and that won't affect people a long way
away from me all over the world
don't buy oceanfront property low-lying
areas around the world from Fairborn in
wales to major cities like Miami could
be flooded according to a report by the
United Nations Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change by 2050 a billion
people could be affected by the climate
crisis human-induced climate change has
a major footprint on the systems we
depend on these changes will continue
for generations to come
this new IPCC special report highlights
the urgency of prioritizing tiny
ambitious and coordinated action
in Italy a quarter of a million cubic
meters of ice are at risk of breaking
off a glacier on Mont Blanc the IPCC
report says some alpine glaciers will
completely disappear this century but
the scientists are most concerned of
what is happening in Antarctica and the
Arctic the glaciers on Svalbard west
coast can retreat by several hundreds of
metres every year their melting from
above and from below you can see the
warm water is eating away at the ice
underneath and is slowly retreating up
onto land the Arctic permafrost ground
frozen for thousands of years is also
thawing and could release billions of
tons of greenhouse gas that could have a
calamitous effect on the climate and the
scientists urged world leaders to take
immediate and ambitious action to cut
carbon emissions Thomas More Sky News in
spar bird the Arctic